so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your host KL
small and today we're talking about the
Industrial Revolution seem like a weird
thing to cover on biographics but it
does you know include know small
biographics on a number of prominent
individuals from within that time period
so it fits with the theme and as with
all videos here at biographics this one
is based on a script submitted To Us by
a member of our writing team that being
Larry holsworth you find links to their
socials below if they've been
provided
beginning in the mid 18th century a
seismic shift in Humanity's existence
altered the Western World it began
largely in Great Britain whoop
expanding through the global Empire over
the ensuing Century rival Nations found
expedient to catch up to the movement
which became known as the first
industrial revolution rather than a
dependent on goods and products being
made by hand by workers who learned
their skills from Master Craftsman
machines Rose to dominate manufacturing
new sources of power drove the machines
beginning with wind and water and
eventually giving way to the emergence
of the steam engine a new form of
Industry developed called manufactur it
which is awesome and I can't believe I
didn't know that sites hired unskilled
workers to operate the machines that
made their products mechanization
replaced hand production the spinning
wheel and weaving of textile shifted
from home production to factories by the
early 19th century the manufacturing of
iron mining of coal processing of
leather goods processing of meat candle
making soap making and many many many
other trades and crafts had shifted from
small businesses to Major manufacturers
these changes inevitably led to changes
in society as a whole cities around the
manufacturers grew more efficient uses
of waterways for shipping of products
led to a boom in the construction of
canals factories perched alongside
rivers and streams developed dams and
spillways to better exploit hydraulic
power the apprenticeship system where
young workers bound themselves to
Masters in order to learn a trade gave
way to Modern employment systems where
daily wages were paid for shift's works
the actual years the Industrial
Revolution falls under and not clearly
defined but the period span both the
American and French revolutions the
expansions of Empires into the Indian
and Pacific Oceans and the opening of
the American West it began in around the
1700s with a shift in one of Humanity's
oldest Necessities the need to make
clothes to protect on themselves from
the elements the textile industry was
the first to be mechanized to create
modern manufacturing and shipping
methods even the first to adopt supply
side engineering though it wasn't yet
called that here is the story of the
Industrial Revolution described by some
historians has and I quote the process
of change from an agrarian and
handicraft economy to one dominated by
industry and machine
manufacturing the simple spinning wheel
and frame Loom are symbols of rural
Simplicity today but in the early 18th
century Britain they were symbolic of
Industry manufacturing of threads Yarns
and cloths was dominated by a cottage
industry where the occupants of
individual Cottages accepted raw
materials from Brokers spun and or wo
them and then return them them to the
broker cages on agricultural land use
this opportunity to create income during
the leaner colder months when
agricultural production was blocked by
you know the snow weaving was
considerably slower than spinning since
the former relied on the output of the
latter and in the 1720s one Weaver
needed the output of four Spinners in
order to produce finished cloth in
usable amounts at the same time finished
cotton products were a major import from
India where the East India Company
exploited a cheap labor available to
produce finished cotton one such product
known as kico became immensely popular
in response the cottage workers
protested to Parliament leading to that
body enacting the kico acts of 1720 in
1721 Parliament banned the importation
of finnished cotton but Exempted raw
cotton for spinning and weaving this led
to an increase in raw cotton entering
Britain from India and the Americas the
need to accommodate the processing of
Raw to finish cotton led to Innovations
from several British inventors none more
important than the 1733 invention of the
flying shuttle by John K of berry so
John K of bu near Lancashire by the end
of the decade Weaver's Productions had
more than double outpacing the ability
of spinners to keep them supplied other
Weavers being more conservative rejected
the flying shut and together with the
Spinners attempt to disrupt technical
progress through petitioning to the king
they failed and that's just one of those
things that happens throughout history
of every time there is this like large
like you know cultural shift towards a
more efficient mechanical method that
makes things easier the people who do it
the more inefficient way will complain
and I know that someone in the comments
going to bring up ai ai can go look the
arrival of strong artificial
intelligence has been inevitable for
decades that's
different like like you know a frying
pan met a
ro is different from a story the part of
your soul goes into a story not into a
frying pan nonetheless they failed to
convince the king other inventions
including further Innovations by K
continued to mechanize the textile
industry in the 1760s water frames for
spinning threads emerge relying on water
power rather than the treel Pumped by
the spinner another Improvement to
spinning came from a multi spindle
device known as the ji which relied on
water power to operate several spinning
wheels simultaneously multiplying the
number of threads created in a given
amount of time so it's called the water
Genny the use of water powerered
machines displaced the cottage workers
and their industry and the manufacturing
of textiles moved to larger
establishments located near a source of
water for power rather than the work
coming to them by Brokers machine
operators went to their work in newly
established factories called Mills in
the textile industry following the
invention of the cotton gin in 1793
which automated the removal of seeds
from the plant raw cotton became a major
cash crop in the United States and a
major import to the British cotton Mills
Manchester and its many surrounding
towns became centers for the production
and warehousing of cotton Manchester
even earned the nickname cottonopolis
which I didn't know and will now be
using exclusively to refer to my manuri
and friends and
family oh how how are things over there
in cottonopolis
[Music]
while water provided a good power source
for factories and Mills located nearby
it was at the best of times unreliable
water levels were subject to the
vagaries of nature another steady source
of power to drive Industrial Development
was needed and it came in the form of
the steam engine like the early
Innovations in textile steam was first
looked upon as a Folly by conservatives
who regarded it as dangerous dirty and
impractical and in many ways they were
right Chief among the problems faced by
proponents of steam power for Mills and
factories was the need to provide Power
via rotating wheel which in turn drove
the Machinery of the Mills James watts
is often credited as the inventor of the
steam engine he was not examples of
working steam engines can be found years
before watt's experiments with the for I
think there's even that one from like
turkey where some guy just invented the
steam engine but then only used it to
spin his damy which you know what Legend
So over, 1400 working Newan steam
engines invented by Thomas nukan in 1712
were employed in Britain before wat's
engine nearly all of them designed for
dewatering coal mines what applied his
attention to the modification of the
steam principle to reduce the operating
cost and design a drive a flywheel which
provided the rotational force with his
partner Matthew Bolton W formed the
manufacturing concern Bolton and W
producing steam engines from 1775 his
early engines burned wood and charcoal
were roundly condemned for their
production of smoke and Cinders steam
engines Al o developed a well-earned
reputation for being dangerous due to
their proclivity for just randomly
exploding seemingly without warning
advances in Metallurgy and safety
controls continue throughout the
Industrial Revolution and in fact
continue to this day steam became the
primary motive force behind the
mechanization of Industry eventually
coal became the fuel of choice in the
coal Rich Britain to power steam engines
when a more practical means of coking
coal was invented in 1768 by Englishmen
John Wilkinson Coke became the preferred
fuel for industrial use and that's a
sentence that can be read numerous
different ways given um the modern way
we interpret someone saying oh I'm
fueled by
Coke prior to the development of a
practical means to produce Coke in
appreciable quantities the fledgeling
iron industry relied on wood and
charcoal to fuel its blast furnaces and
forges like the textile industry before
it iron production was localized nearly
entirely within areas where you could
find iron ore water Limestone and wood
at first fires to smell the ore were of
wood then charcoal made locally from the
wood then coal the production of iron in
Britain was so cost prohibitive at one
point it was actually cheaper to just
import iron from Scandinavia prior to
the Industrial Revolution several
factors contribut to the emergence of
the iron industry during the Industrial
Revolution Chief among them was
increasing demand particularly for nails
and other construction hardware and I'm
sure we've all heard or familiar with
those stories like people burning down
wooden houses to retrieve the nails like
contained therein because the iron in
the nails was so hard to produce that it
was worth burning down an entire house
to get them back advancing Technologies
in other Industries such as textile and
steam engines added to the increased
demand for iron new techniques developed
by Iron Monga such as Henry C led to
improv quality and faster production by
the late 18th century blast furnaces
were relocated to Coal rich areas and
regions known for the production of iron
were also areas where coal was mined and
coked as such they became areas with
wide and vast employment opportunities
cour processes among other things
lowered the carbon concent of cast ion
making it less brittle he also developed
Innovations in the process of making pig
iron and RW iron including the use of
mass production if anyone curious about
why it was called pig iron it was so
named because it was formed in ingots
cooled in sand along the length of the
runner little piggies which is cute I
like that they resemble like little
piglets suckling their mother and was so
named and that's adorable as for the
uses of pig ion it was used primarily to
be remelted and worked into rot iron
because it was intended to be reworked
into rot iron is sometimes referred to
as crude iron when steel emerged as the
primary metal for industry in the late
Industrial Age Pig Iron's major use was
in the manufacturing of Steel like think
of it like when you use like Microsoft
Edge to download Chrome so they were
basically using pig iron to fuel its own
obsolescence and steel owing to it being
just better than iron in most regards
led to a Second Industrial Revolution
this isn't to say that raw iron didn't
have its uses and was in fact the
backbone of the first Industrial
Revolution used to manufacture rails
beams Hardware boilers machine frames
and a myriad of other uses basically all
areas of Industry used it and you know
today still use I've got cast iron pan
apparently it's better 's it to cut my
eggs in the morning I'm a cut like Shak
shuker in it moving swiftly on like just
to clarify the definitions here R iron
is iron which can be further worse
whereas cast iron being more brittle
cannot of the 1700s iron was used to
build Bridges and frame buildings it was
also used to manufacture the boilers and
other components of watts and Bolton
steam engines which in turn drove the
machine machinery for the iron textile
and coal Industries as well as others
moving away from Britain for a moment
the North American colonies participated
in the revolution to an extent with
widely differing results in the northern
regions coal mines coking facilities and
Iron Works emerged creating new cities
far from the earliest towns huddled on
the Atlantic coast Western Pennsylvania
New York and New England all developed
manufacturers in the manner of their
British counterparts along with streams
of New England in particular textile
mills created new skylines and attracted
new residents to the
towns
at the onset of the Industrial
Revolution Goods move from producers to
Consumers via waterways or roads both
were subject to weather streams run
freely and often dangerously during the
wet Seasons but dried often to a mere
trickle in the hot months roads were
little more than widen mud paths often
impassible oxen donkeys and horses
provided power but were limited in the
amount they could move like even the
hardiest Beast of Burden couldn't hope
to move several tons of iron in one go
the creation of reliable transport
networks became critical as advant
production methods increase the output
of factories mines and Mills an early
solution was the creation of canals and
improvements along navigable waterways
canals were nothing new in the British
AOL the Romans built canals for the
purpose of draining agricultural lands
and improving navigation during the
first century ad Roman canals move Goods
primarily agricultural products nearly
40 miles between what are the modern day
regions of York and Cambridge like I I
live near one you can just go to it
people live in boats on them which is
fun like there's a guy in one of the
boats has like a big widecreen TV that
takes up one of his boat and it's like
that guy living his best life as such
the Industrial Revolution is known as
the hey day of canalization with Great
Britain leading the way in 1757 the
sanki Canal open in Northern Britain
connecting the C fields near St Helens
to the river Mery and the port of
Liverpool wind was the primary mive
power for the first Canal boats its
success led to an explosion of canal
building in Great Britain followed by a
similar spike in Canal Construction in
the United States most of the canals
relied on animal power to pull boats the
toe paths alongside the canal allowed
the animals to pull lows which dwarf
those haed by their Brethren on roads a
single horse for example could pull a
canal boat Laden with up to 30 tons of
goods more than 10 times the amount
possible with a wagon on the roads of
the day out there like myself who's
concerned for the horses and the mules
and the donkeys pulling these things it
also works out for them because you
didn't need to just use one horse that
would just get knackered by the end of
its trip and they change the horse
usually at every lock allowing it to
rest so that was nice I always feel bad
when you see like a donkey like they're
such Noble looking creatur features so
dumb in North America canals were viewed
more as a means of transporting goods
through the barrier of the Appalachian
Mountains bringing raw materials from
the West to the consumers and shippers
of the East as such they required
numerous locks to counter the grades and
were expensive and timec consuming to
build steam power appeared on the canals
in the early 19th century steam powered
Canal Boats were not significantly
faster than animal drawn ones nor could
they haul substantially larger loads by
the 1820s in North America and Great
Britain the canals had reached their
heights within a decade their use had
begun to decline the steam engine had
found a more favorable application for
moving goods and people the
railroad the railroads actually appeared
before the steam locomotive despite the
fact they're eternally coupled in
people's minds the first use of a
railway to carry Goods took place in
1802 in tikol England the rail cars
connected tikel and its outlying areas
to the Ashby Canal its purpose was to
convey lime Limestone and bricks from
the various yards around tikn the rail
cars which traveled on several branches
as well as the trunk line of the
railroad called a Tramway were initially
pulled by horses and mules you go horses
and mules saving Humanity's ass for
thousands of years this was the first
successful industrial Railroad and it
remained in service with some
improvements such as like know adding a
train until 1913 moving Limestone was
also the initial purpose of the Swansea
mumbles Railway which opened in 1804 and
by 1807 the railway was conveying
passengers in hor drawn carriages as
well as Limestone just love the idea of
A horra Train That's So quaint to me the
use of steam powered locomotives began
in Britain in the 1820s and they were at
first considered a daring novelty the
engines of the day were noisy belt dark
heavy costic smoke interlac with glowing
Cinders and as noted earlier had a
fairly well-deserved reputation for just
exploding at random by 1831 you could
expect to find speeds on Railways of up
to 25 mph and this gives me an
opportunity to talk about one of my
favorite facts from history when
railroads and Railways were first
becoming a thing women were heavily
advised Ed by the men in their lives and
doctors and experts not to ride them
because traveling at such high speeds
speeds remember being like 25 M hour
might cause their uteruses to fall out
of their
bodies
and one day I would love to have the
confidence of a man telling a woman you
can't go on the train you uterus will
Fallout moving swiftly on the canal
simply could not compete with such
blistering speeds nor could they take
advantage of the rapidly evolving
technological improvements to steam
engines railroads demanded improvements
in the quality and durability of iron
and later steel they built larger and
more powerful engines rail car frames
and trucks Bridges Rail Yards and all
the infrastructure needed for the much
needed expansion to produce more and
better iron the industry required better
cing methods to remove the impurities
from coal as well as vast amounts of
coke delivered to their foundaries the
railroads coal mines Coke manufacturers
iron mines and blast furnaces became
mutually dependent on one another with
improvements in each benefiting the
others Ci's industrial centers and ports
became linked by a network which
delivered prosperity and progress never
before achieved in human
society manufacturers needed workers to
operate and maintain these new machines
that drove their new Industries these
workers could be found in populated
areas in Great Britain places like
Manchester Leeds Liverpool dunde
Edinburgh Cardiff and many others
including the city I'm in right now
Sheffield which is also like a center
for steel production even to this day
I've got some Sheffield steel knocking
about somewhere but it's like a spoon I
don't really think I was going hold up a
spoon and say this was made in the city
that I live in it's a spoon but it's
still a point of Pride for many people
who live here we even have like a steel
Museum anyway these cities became
industrial complexes cluttered with
factories warehouses and shipping
centers over in the United States New
England became a textile industry
Powerhouse similar growth in various
Industries occurred throughout the
United States particularly in the north
and Western cities of Buffalo Cleveland
and Cincinnati in both Britain and
America immigration of workers exploded
during the Industrial Revolution Irish
workers left their Homeland for both
Britain and America to work the mines
build canals and railroads and labor in
the foundaries the warehouses the docks
or the Looms a relatively new form of
housing evolved from this multiple
families occupied rooms in buildings
often with several floors the buildings
grouped together in neighborhoods within
cities they became the tenaments that
led to the population explosion in
various cities around the globe so
rather than learning a trade or a craft
that would lead to becoming a master
Carpenter Iron Monger or Weaver men
instead took jobs operating the machines
that supplanted these professions they
labored in the new factories often for
six days per week performing simple
menial tasks to keep the machines
running in return for their labor they
received a wage there were no benefits
and no breaks other than for a simple
midday meal the newly veled labor force
existed to feed the machines the raw
materials they required and deliver
their products to the next machine in
the chain it just so happens that one of
those resources was human labor As
Cities grew so did their social problems
basic services such as water supply
sewage removal Transportation education
and Crime Control were all strained by
the influx of new workers and their
families it was possible to survive on
the prevailing wages of a time
especially if there was more than one
wage earner in a household but thriving
or elevating one's status was next to
Impossible seemingly by Design between
1800 and 1850 the accepted second half
of the Industrial Revolution the
population of Great Britain doubled and
by the latter year about half of
Britain's population lived in cities and
towns similar numbers apply to the
United States especially in regions
north of the Ohio river and east of the
Mississippi River the crowding of cities
coupled with the expansion of industrial
areas within those same cities led to
overcrowding in the tenaments and
densely populated Urban cores while the
owners and stockholders of the emerging
corporations in Industries acquired
fortunes and lived in conspicuous
Comfort the workers running the machines
existed in less than idilic
circumstances death the author is going
to let that one sit
a through the early Decades of the
Industrial Revolution communication
between remote areas remained much as it
had been for the preceding centuries
messages whether in writing or verbal
were carried by criers or postmen who
relied on two legs four legs or some
combination thereof during the
Napoleonic Wars the transmission of
messages via longdistance semaphor
stations was developed in Europe where
encountered problems with obstructed
visibility based on weather conditions
during the Industrial Revolution
advances in the science of
electromagnetics Drew the attention of
several diverse entities on both sides
of the Atlantic in Britain William Cook
and Charles wheatstone devised a method
of transmitting messages using
electromagnetic pulses in 1837 they
patented their invention and by the end
of the following year a 13m stretch of
Britain's Great Western Railway was
flanked by Telegraph wires carrying
coded messages in seconds their system
used multiple wires and batteries and
presented complicated codes to its
operators in the United States on the
other hand a much better known
individual called Samuel Moss A Portrait
Painter of considerable Renown among his
subjects were President James Monroe and
the Marque de Lafayette learned of the
British system and developed
improvements that allowed messages to be
sent along a single electrical line
Mor's system eventually became the
international standard for telegraphs to
make transmission even clearer mors even
invented a system that continues to bear
his name mors code and again as an aside
I don't know when else I get a chance to
talk about this in a video people out
there probably know one bit of M code if
if they're wholly unfamiliar with the
the language system as a whole that'll
be SOS think it's like it's three dashes
three dots three dashes which even if
that's wrong it's technically still
right and other lesser fact touting
channels and websites will tell you that
SOS stands for something like save our
souls which is a acronym that being an
acronym that's applied retroactively um
to a group of letters and in fact SOS
meant nothing that was precisely the
reason it was chosen as the
international symbol for I am in
distress because there was no other
understood meaning of those three
letters in a row and one of the reasons
SOS was picked in addition to that is
because SOS regardless of which order
it's transmitted in will always be
understood to mean SOS because it's just
three dots three dashes three dots three
dashes like done in sequence you you
listen to it for more than a few seconds
you'll notice that it's just it's repeat
it's basically a repeating code of two
letters similarly when written down SOS
can be read backwards upside down Every
Which Way but Loose and still be
understood to read slos and that's why
it was picked just that's just a fun
story about mors code like the one fact
about mors code that I know I thought
I'd slip in uh before we move on with
this video about the Industrial
Revolution Telegraph lines soon
cluttered the skies and cities of towns
and for longer distances Transmissions
often ran along existing right of way
for railroads and highways the telegraph
revolutionized Communications allowing
near instantaneous Communications and
dissemination of information to
businesses governments newspapers
individuals between nations and of
course individuals by the mid 19th
century access to Telegraph traffic was
critical for virtually all forms of
Industry telegraphs order products and
materials M their locations follow their
transfer and report on the activities of
the competition yeah now that is a spy
movie I would not
watch the industrial revolution saw an
entirely New Concept develop in Industry
one that would have been unthinking able
in a non-mechanized age so for the first
time in history mechanized tools were
being developed for the express purpose
of making other tools or components of
other tools and machines the development
of tools designed to shape materials
into other usable forms created one of
the first Machine Tools machine tools
were a critical component of the age in
that they allowed for the assembly of
machines using interchangeable parts and
just yeah it's one of those things is
it's like when you go might watch a show
like how it's made it's like oh we have
a machine here all it does is like roll
the TW in a very certain way you think
well someone to make that machine
someone out there as a machine that
makes the machines that make twink Cas
and then presumably there's a machine
that makes the machine that makes the
machine that makes Twinkies and so on
and so forth and so that's why you need
machine pressy someone's got to build it
so until the Industrial Revolution the
simple screw was an expensive
handcrafted piece of Hardware made by
Artisans to exacting specifications
provided to them the development of the
screw cutting lathe in 1775 adapted hand
operated techniques used by Artisans
from Archimedes to Leonardo da Vinci to
the mass production of precision screw
screws The Humble threaded Fastener
became a critical part of
industrialization as it remains so in
the 21st century other critical machine
tools that emerged during the Industrial
Revolution included the milling machine
used to remove unwanted materials in
order to achieve a desired shape And the
cylinder boring tool which created
precisely Dimension cylinders the latter
was a critical component of steam
engines locomotives and other machines
that powered the Industrial Age Machine
Tools remained critical in manufacturing
in the 21st century and often computer
controlled achieving a Precision their
earliest proponents could scarcely dare
to
imagine he often said that the
Industrial Revolution Mar the Western
World shift from an agrarian to an
industrial society certainly agriculture
did not Escape its influence as machines
were developed to plant Harvest and
process many crops industrialization of
machines also influenced which crops
were planted the demand for cotton in
British and American textile mills
contributed to the labor intensive crop
dominating the fields of the American
Deep South the industrial revolution saw
rise in income per capita simultaneously
with an increas in population it also
marked an increase in children surviving
into adulthood you know so they could
work in those factories they also saw an
increase in child labor oh the children
yearn for the minds as there were few
laws existing to the contrary not until
1844 did the factory acts in Britain
establish that children under 9 years of
age were not allowed to labor in the
factories those over the age of nine
were limited by law to a 12-hour workday
6 days per week so that be a reminder to
everybody out there the existence of
child labor laws um is proof that if um
corporations could they would indeed
exploit children for labor and it's only
the law telling that they can't that
prevents them from doing so well many of
the more important developments of the
Industrial Revolution have been
discussed there were many other events
prevailing in the period including the
manufacturing distribution of gas for
lighting and heat the impact of Cholera
and other diseases on the cities in the
workforce the resistance of the Lites
and the illegality of Labor and trade
unions cities such as London Manchester
Glasgow and Pittsburgh gained Fame for
the clouds of smoke which obscured them
its dangers then pretty much wholly
unknown fossil fuels were burned
indiscriminately their clouds seen as
signs of progress in Industry rather
than carbon Footprints the waste of
industrial plants was dumped untreated
into public waterways where it mingled
with the offall of cities and towns
children were seen as laborers laborers
themselves as replaceable as cogs in the
machine known as progress there is no
doubt the first Industrial Revolution
changed forever the way people lived and
work worked but not always for the
better mass production replaced local
craftsmanship Artisans were replaced by
Factory workers cities became
overcrowded crime rates Rose foul air of
foul water marked urban areas the DS of
the workplace breakdowns rotating
machines excessive heat explosions mine
catastrophes noise and a multitude of
other factors were of little concern to
employers they were all signs of
progress measured by the expansion of
facilities and of course profits this
was the Heyday of unfettered unrelenting
capitalism the Industrial Revolution did
see a shift from an agrarian to an
industrial society it saw Humanity using
Newfound industrial might to exploit the
bounties of the planet without regard to
the problems it created for future
Generations its impact is still felt to
this very day in industry in society in
education geopolitics and of course the
environment and as far as can be
foreseen well into the future and I'm of
course reminded right now of that uh
very poignant quite harrowing quote from
Albert Einstein when asked to Muse on
the thought of uh industry and warfare I
do not know with which weapons World War
III will be fought but I do know that
World War I will be fought with sticks
and stones anyway I hope everyone
enjoyed this video I certainly enjoyed
presenting it and yeah if you did like
the video like leave a like if you got
anything to say about it if you got some
feedback something you'd like us to
cover in another video do so in the
comments subscribe for more like this as
always go follow the writer of this
video Larry holsworth and the socials
that provide for us below myself if you
want to see more of my work I'm on
Twitter I'm on Twitch I'm on YouTube at
fact Fe with Cal Smallwood and Wiki
weekends as well as the sister channels
to biographics um Geographics and top
10s I'm nearly running out of fingers
now so I'm going to call it there and
just as I always like to say to everyone
out there watching at home have the day
you all
deserve